[Music]
listening is not just a matter of using
your ears it's also about using other
parts of your body and if you do it
correctly it will have a great impact on
the way you pay attention and retain
information and in this short video I'm
going to show you a very simple
technique just to do that
[Music]
[Music]
so here it is my taking note session is
over it took me only five minutes and
the benefits are enormous just listening
to a piece of information and jotting
down my notes in this position help me
pay attention to what that person was
saying and at the same time I was paying
attention to what I was writing so the
retention rate doubles or triples and
it's really simple to do whatever you
can just take a very important piece of
information relevant and important for
you and take notes because it's gonna
make a difference there's a lot of ways
to take notes but the important thing is
that you get into the habit of taking
notes you will figure out your way on
the go and as I said it has amazing
benefits and you should definitely give
it a try not only to learn languages but
also in general to retain information
that is really good and relevant and
useful so now I have one question for
you I want to ask you have you ever
taken notes and how do you take notes
and have you ever taken notes to learn
foreign languages and what do you think
is the best way to take notes in order
to absorb words and pay attention to the
phonetic fabric of a language I'm really
curious about your experiences you learn
strategy so please drop a comment in the
comment section below and I truly hope
to see you there
taking notes is really simple to do you
just have to have a computer or a mobile
device you just have to have your
wonderful piece of paper a pencil and
just jot down the notes of what you hear
you can use multiple systems I've shown
you one example of taking notes but if
you get into the habit of taking notes
and you do this maybe once in a while
when you really find something that
really interests you then five minutes
doing this are five minutes very well
spent because you'll pay attention much
more and you retain much more and you
have to remember that attention is the
very first form or retention
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]